da-da-da-da-da-da here we go the premier
of the what's the title of this American
greed episode is there like a title yet
or the Bonnie and Clyde of mortgage
fraud the Bonnie and Clyde of mortgage
fraud here we go ladies and gentlemen in
this episode of American greed he had
millions and millions and millions and
millions and more millions Matt Cox and
Rebecca Hall Matt says I got to get out
of here I got a league you know you want
to come the Bonnie and Clyde of mortgage
fraud this plan was to get as much as he
can look at Judy look at that hairline I
know that's rough
you look Hispanic what's the hand
English on your awesome dude that's
that's Allison at that point I really
did I thought they'll never catch me
[Music]
this is kind of what your value tainment
podcast is gonna look like yeah
[Music]
in Tampa Florida a young man named Matt
Cox is making a killing in real estate
he has fast cars lots of cash there's
always a pretty woman at his side part
of his character was like this mystery
man like this mysterious like who is he
[Music]
Allyson Arnold is new to temp so who is
Allyson Arnold again Allyson Arnold was
a mortgage broker that was working for
another mortgage company and she and the
guy the guy that owned the mortgage
company it you know his name is Eddie
Stralis Eddie owned a mortgage company
called Tampa Heights mortgage and she
was working there well Eddie called me
up one day he's like look she's got this
[ __ ] she's a mortgage broker she's got
this loan we can't get it closed I don't
know what to do can you talk to her so I
go in I look at the thing and I remember
the the comparable sales were too far
away and there were no comparable sales
that justified the the sales price right
in the area and I was like look they're
going three and a half miles away and
she was like yeah that's what they said
and I was like look everything's good in
it but the appraisals [ __ ] up you need
to and she's like well what do I do I
said we'll give me the file and I'll
close it and she's like well what do I
get I was like well I mean I'll give you
500 bucks she's like I need what are you
five hundred dollars I was like you
can't close it you can't close the loan
it's done he's got a real estate
commission off it these people want to
buy the house give me the file you're
good
thanks I appreciate it 500 bucks that's
what you get for a referral fee and
she's like I I really need the money and
then look you saw her look at her you
know I'm a sucker
I mean box she's adorable so which you
know is what's wrong - you know judge
her on that she was also a very smart
person single mother single mother
single mother which we know I like who -
Tampa yes he's recently divorced
to raise a young son Allison meets Matt
Cox in the spring of 2003 and quickly
begins to fall for him he had a nice
place he had really nice furniture he
was just really well connected his
friends were all young and successful
I thought the mortgage business was that
Matt Cox is a mortgage broker real
estate rehabber an overall Renaissance
man who'sa talented artist to paint
elaborate murals and all his properties
and he's obsessed Wow he told that con
man well that's actually an artist by
the name of Tamra dealer pack she's one
of my favorite artists and I would take
I would make collages of her artwork
because I'm the place I bought was built
in like 1901 and she was circular I'd
say 1920s which was the art deco so it
was close it's a different style but
whatever it was close it was so I baked
collages and I did I mean and I paint
them and and they were cool but the
Alison thing I was gonna say what ended
up happening was I ended up splitting
and I think I split the Commission with
her so but I ended up closing the loan
that she couldn't close okay and so she
ended up coming to work for me because
she was like look I can't you know you I
couldn't close this thing down here god
you handed you guys closed it like that
I said look come work for me I talk
about I talk about all that in this book
look hahaha he not going in the movie
theater and we would go and see movies
like the one that I fell in love with
that we saw was the Italian Job to us
and he just loved that movie he's like
they got away with it you know he loved
when people got away with that don't
break my heart you told me you were
through after this I am
like his heroes in the movies Matt Cox
dreams of doing one big score and then
going legit here's the plan you'll
assume fake identities take out multiple
mortgage Lowe did how did they get those
ID cards I was just thinking that
because you know I've only seen this
once do they make those no no those
right there I think those are the actual
ones I think the Secret Service probably
gave that literally the Secret Service's
interviewed I'm sure they gave full
cooperates in the US Attorney's Office
was interviewed him they wanted this
multiple mortgage loans on properties he
doesn't own and pocket the money on
average each loan will be around
$100,000 buy some real estate alison
goes to work at matt Cox's mortgage
company not knowing what's in store for
her just a few weeks later Cox calls in
a favor when Alison was down on her luck
he helped her out he rented an apartment
for Alison and bought her new furniture
now it's payback time
sinister is that true that that's
actually true I did buy her she had she
was going it does sound sinister she was
going through a divorce first of all
first of all I don't owe you anything I
met you because you gave me alone I gave
you your money yeah you wanted to come
work for me you came to work for me
great I gave her a bunch more loans she
closed more loans these are fraudulent
loans
she knows that fraud to be being done
there so I'm not luring you in you know
what's going Yuva closed several loans
at this point if they're fraud yeah
so but one of the things was she was
living in her husband's house and they
were going through a divorce she wasn't
divorced already she was getting a
divorce so I was I'm sleeping with her
I'm sleeping with another girl named
Jana so these two are fighting back and
forth it's just a [ __ ] soap opera bro
Jana lives across the street from me
she's got a [ __ ] girlfriend that
chick hates my guts
I mean it's just [ __ ] ridiculous bro
I mean Jana's chasing [ __ ] Alison out
of the house she's chasing other girls
out I mean it's just it's [ __ ]
outrageous so the point is is that I end
up she needs a place to stay and she's
like look I'm in my husband's house you
know Jana showed up at the [ __ ] house
one day at her husband's house where she
lives and it's telling him she's [ __ ]
his boss he's just ridiculous so he's
like you got to get out so she gets out
and she's like what do I do and like
look well I don't want her to move in
with me I mean I like Alison but I can't
ever move in with me you know so I go
and I rent her an apartment in the name
of Jane Brandon Green one of my fake
people so I rent the apartment I then
take his credit cards and I go buy her a
bunch of [ __ ] at home at a rooms to go
buy her a bunch of furniture all Brandon
green Brandon Green buy she's got it
like a was a 2-bedroom 2-bath nice place
in Ybor City and when that new huge
apartment complex
so she moves in there I give her [ __ ]
money I pay her [ __ ] rent I don't owe
you anything but I'm doing all of this
but the way they make it sound he's you
know he got her a place he'd she owes
him you owe me anything she's asking me
to commit fraud but but you know but I
mean what's but but what they are saying
is yes
they come to work for me that's true she
did come to work for me she was making
money doing fraud I did rent your place
so you know to me that's like a 90%
that's like 90% true I mean they're just
kind of tweaking it
he's like Alison I'm helping you and my
investors are helping you so that we
have your loyalty so that you'll do
anything for us there are no investment
the con man wants is for Alison to be
his partner in crime he wants her to
assume a fake identity and apply for a
mortgage loan that's once or twice but
seven times with seven different banks
he's already stolen an identity form the
name Rosita Perez a real person who
supposedly crossed a friend of his the
funny thing is look at me I've got
bluish green eyes I had blond hair at
the time pale skin and I was poor
trained to be Rosita Perez the bankers
the closer for the title company they're
like how'd you get this name you're not
Puerto Rican or Spanish are you and my
license that I had brown eyes and I
clearly did it
maybe Alison looks too innocent to pull
off a con whatever the reason the first
time she tries it she's successful she
walks away from the bank with a check
for 117 thousand dollars
what was that about
[Music]
[Laughter]